7:00.
TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HAPPY TUESDAY.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE YOU BACK
ABOUT A YEAR AND A FEW MONTHS
TODAY THE DAY AMERICA CHANGED.
THIS REALLY WAS THE PIVOT POINT.
IT WAS THE HEIGHT OF THE YEAR AT
BLM RIOTS EARLY LAST SUMMER AND
RIOTERS IN MINNEAPOLIS HAD JUST
TORCHED A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
BUILDINGS AND STANDING IN FRONT
OF THEM WAS AN MSNBC REPORTER
WHO WAS BROADCASTING LIVE FROM
THE SCENE.
THE MOB BEGAN BY TORCHING SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE CITY,
INCLUDING A LIQUOR STORE THEY
LOOTED FIRST, NATURALLY.
THAN IS THE RIOTING ACCELERATED,
THEY WALKED DOWN STREET, BURNED
ON THE MINNEAPOLIS POLICE
STATION.
AS YOU SAW THAT HAPPEN YOU
REALIZE THIS WAS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT FROM ANYTHING WE HAVE
SEEN BEFORE.
WE HAVE SEEN RIOTS BEFORE IN
1992, THE RODNEY KING VERDICT,
RIOTERS IN LOS ANGELES TORCHED A
LOT OF THE MIDDLE OF THAT CITY,
BUT THEY DID NOT BURN ANY POLICE
STATIONS BECAUSE YOU CANNOT BURN
A POLICE STATION BECAUSE THERE
ARE POLICE THERE AND THEY ARE
ARMED AND THEY REPRESENT THE
LAW, THEY ENFORCE THE LAW, SO
YOU CANNOT BRING ON POLICE
STATIONS.
IF THEY LET YOU DO THAT, YOU
KNOW THE WHOLE SYSTEM -- GO BUT
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED,
JUST DAYS LAST SUMMER.
THE IMPLICATION OF THAT WAS VERY
CLEAR, THIS IS WHY WE DO NOT
ALLOW POLICE STATIONS TO GET
BURNED.
THE MESSAGE IT SENDS IS THEY
CAN'T PROTECT YOU, THEY CAN'T
EVEN PROTECT THEMSELVES.
SO THE POLICE ARE NOT IN CHARGE,
LEGITIMATE -- OF THE MOB IS NOW
IN CHARGE.
SO AS THAT IS HAPPENING, THAT
HAPPENS TO BECOME AS NOTED,
REPORTERS STANDING RIGHT THERE
WITH A MICROPHONE AND CAMERA
TAKING PICTURES DIRECTLY INTO
YOUR LIVING ROOM.
THAT REPORTER WAS -- HE IS
FAMOUSLY NOT SUPER BRIGHT, BUT
HE WAS ON THE SCENE!
WATCH HOW HE DESCRIBED WHAT WAS
HAPPENING RIGHT BEHIND HIM.
>> THERE IS NO ABILITY TO BRING
ANYBODY IN HERE TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM, SO I WANT TO BE CLEAR
AND HOW I CHARACTERIZE THIS.
THIS IS A PROTEST.
IT IS NOT, GENERALLY SPEAKING,
UNRULY.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
YOU'VE PROBABLY SEEN IT A
HUNDRED TIMES, WATCH IT EVERY
MORNING JUST FOR EDIFICATION.
IT IS MOSTLY A PROTEST, HE SAID,
FLAMES IN THE BACKGROUND.
IT IS GENERALLY SPEAKING ON
UNRULY.
STANDING IN FRONT OF A BURNING
BUILDING.
SO THAT TAPE, AS WE JUST SAID,
IS VERY FAMOUS, AND IT A LOT OF
PEOPLE LOOK AT THAT AND SAY THAT
REPORTER IS A, WHICH OF COURSE
IS TRUE.
HE COULDN'T EVEN DESCRIBE WHAT
HE WAS SEEING ACCURATELY.
WHAT A GAFFE.
IT WAS NOT A GAFFE, IT WAS NOT
TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT.
IT WAS MSNBC'S EXPLICIT
EDITORIAL POLICY TO LIE ABOUT
WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING, TO
CHARACTERIZE VIOLENT RIOTS AS
PEACEFUL PROTESTS, AND IT WAS
NOT JUST ALI VELSHI, LATER THAT
VERY DAY, ANOTHER
EXPLAINED, WE ARE QUOTING, "THIS
WILL GUIDE OUR REPORTING."
THE SITUATION ON THE GROUND IN
MINNEAPOLIS IS FUMING AND THAT
HAS BEEN VIOLENCE, IT IS MOST
ACCURATE AT THIS TIME TO
DESCRIBE WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE
IS PROTESTS.
NOT RIOTS.
[LAUGHS]
PAGING DR. ORWELL.
THEY ARE NOT RIOTS.
THE ONE THING THEY ARE NOT, THEY
ARE NOT RIOTS, NOT AT ALL.
MSNBC WAS NOT AN OUTLIER IN
ADOPTING THIS POLICY, THE
REALITY DENIAL.
CNN'S COVERAGE.
>> AND LET'S NOT FORGET, IF
ANYONE IS JUDGING THIS, I AM NOT
JUDGING THIS, I AM JUST
WONDERING WHAT IS GOING ON?
OUR COUNTRY WAS STARTED
BECAUSE -- THE BOSTON TEA PARTY.
RIOTING.
SO DO NOT GET IT TWISTED AND
THINK THAT OH, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT HAS NOT NEVER HAPPENED
BEFORE AND THIS IS SO TERRIBLE
AND WHERE ARE WE AND THESE
SAVAGES AND ALL THAT, THIS IS
HOW THIS COUNTRY WAS STARTED.
>> Tucker: YEAH, THIS IS
TOTALLY NORMAL, WE HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH US FOR HUNDREDS OF
YEARS.
SAM ADAMS HIMSELF TORCHED A
WENDY'S AND LOOTED A LIQUOR
STORE BEFORE BURNING DOWN THE
POLICE STATION IN DOWNTOWN
MINNEAPOLIS, THAT'S HOW THIS
COUNTRY STARTED.
WE ALWAYS HAD RIOTS AND LOOTING,
VIRTUALLY EVERY DAY.
IT'S TOTALLY NORMAL.
SO YOUR JOB AS A VIEWER, PER
CNN, MSNBC,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THE
ATLANTIC, "THE WASHINGTON POST"
COME ALL THE REST OF THEM, WAS S
JUST THE WAY THINGS ARE IN THE
WAY THEY HAVE ALWAYS BEEN, AND
ACCEPT IT.
MY COUNTRY YOUR ANCESTORS BUILT
IS ON FIRE, BUT SHOT UP
BECAUSE YOUR ANCESTORS ALSO
BURNED IT DOWN.
NOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
IN FACT, IT IS GROTESQUELY
UNTRUE AND YET TO BE
HISTORICALLY ILLITERATE TO
BELIEVE IT, BUT IT WORKED, AS
PROPAGANDA DOES AND THAT IS WHY
THEY DO IT.
SO INSTEAD OF PUSHING BACK
AGAINST THIS RIOTING, MOST
AMERICANS KIND OF WENT ALONG
WITH IT.
WELL, IT DOESN'T LOOK QUITE
RIGHT TO ME BUT THIS IS HOW OUR
COUNTRY STARTED.
THAT IS WHAT DON LEMON SAID.
IN OTHER WORDS, AS YOUR QUALITY
OF LIFE DECLINES, YOU ARE
INSTRUCTED NOT TO NOTICE.
THIS TREND HAS CONTINUED.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" JUST WENT
RAN THIS HEADLINE AND WE ARE
QUOTING, "DON'T RANT ABOUT
SHORT-STAFFED STORES AND SUPPLY
CHAIN WOES," RATHER THAN "LIVING
CONSTANTLY ON THE VERGE OF
THROWING FITS, WE DO OURSELVES A
FAVOR BY CONSCIOUSLY LOWERING
EXPECTATIONS."
GOT THAT?
SO IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE FACT
THE SHELVES ARE BARE IN YOUR
LOCAL STORES, DON'T THROW A FIT,
DON'T BE AN ENTITLED LITTLE
TOOL, LOWER YOUR EXPECTATIONS.
WHAT DID YOU EXPECT IN AMERICA?
COME ON.
REDLINES.
WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD BREAD LINES.
IS CHARMINGLY RETRO, THESE BREAD
LINES.
DON'T COMPLAIN.
AS YOUR LIFE BECOMES WORSE AND
AS YOUR COUNTRY DEGRADES.
THAT IS THE MESSAGE, NOT
SURPRISINGLY, THAT MESSAGE IS
COMING DIRECTLY FROM THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE MAKING YOUR LIFE WORSE
AND DESTROY THE COUNTRY, THAT OF
COURSE WOULD BE THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO BELIEVE THIS
PERSONALLY, NOT SOME MOCK-UP OF
A GENDER STUDIES STUDENTS.
TODAY SHE WAS ASKED ABOUT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN PROBLEMS, LIKE OUR
PORTS ARE SHUT DOWN, WHAT DO WE
DO?
WATCH AS SHE MARKS THE
REPORTER'S QUESTION, HOW DARE
YOU ASK?
WATCH THIS.
>> JUST A QUESTION ON THIS, ON
THE SUPPLY CHAINS ISSUE --
>> YEAH.
>> ACTIONS THE PRESIDENT HAS
TAKEN P.R. BUT IT WAS CLEAR IN
MARCH OF 2020,
WHEN COVID HIT, SUPPLY CHAINS
ACROSS THE WORLD HAS BEEN
DISRUPTED, EVEN AS SORT OF THE
FIGHT BACK AGAINST COVID
PROCEEDED.
IT WAS QUICKLY CONCLUDED THINGS
ARE NOT IMPROVING ON SUPPLY
CHAINS, PEOPLE CANNOT GET
DISHWASHERS AND FURNITURE'S AND
TREADMILLS DELIVERED ON TIME, NL
SORTS OF OTHER THINGS, SO WHY N-
>> OF THE TRAGEDY OF THE
TREADMILL DELAYED.
>> BUT THE SERIOUS POINT IS WHY
DIDN'T THE PRESIDENT TO ACT
SOONER, IN A MORE AGGRESSIVE
WAY?
>> Tucker: YOU ARE COMPLAINING
ABOUT NOT HAVING A TREADMILL?
SETTLE DOWN, KAREN!
WHAT, DO YOU WANT TO EXERCISE?
YOU HAVE NETFLIX AND WEED, SHUT
UP, GET BACK TO YOUR QUEUE, BE
HAPPY, LOWER YOUR EXPECTATIONS.
AND IF YOU DO OUTSIDE, IF YOU
NOTICE THE WALGREENS' FOR
EXAMPLE CLOSED, AND SO IS THE
CVS, BECAUSE EVERYTHING IN THERE
HAS BEEN STOLEN BY THIEVES
WHO HAVE NOW REDEFINED CIVIL
RIGHTS PROTESTERS, STOP
COMPLAINING, KAREN.
SAN FRANCISCO HAS VERY FEW
WALGREENS OR CVSS OR STORES LIKE
THAT LEFT BECAUSE THEY'VE ALL
BEEN LOOTED.
BY CIVIL RIGHTS PROTESTERS.
BUT THAT IS NOT A PROBLEM,
ACCORDING TO THE MAYOR OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
IN FACT, AS JIM EXPLAINS IN
THIS AMAZING PIECE OF TAPE, IT
IS WALGREENS FAULT.
>> ULTIMATELY, YOU KNOW, THEY
MADE THEIR DECISION.
WE HAVE TRIED TO WORK WITH THEM
IN ORDER TO ENSURE WE ARE
COVERED IN TERMS OF HAVING
PHARMACIES ALL ACROSS THE CITY.
THIS IS GOING TO OF COURSE IN
FACT A LOT OF OUR NEIGHBORHOODS,
BUT I WOULDN'T SAY -- GO AS FAR
AS TO SAY THEY CAN'T DO
BUSINESS.
THEY STILL HAVE A LOT OF STORES,
EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK FROM ALMOST
EVERY CORNER, YOU WILL SEE A
WALGREENS, AND SOME OF THESE
STORES ARE NOT JUST CLOSING
BECAUSE OF RETAIL DEATH, THEY
ARE NOT NECESSARILY BRINGING IN
THE SALES THEY WANT TO BE OR IF
I DON'T WANT TO ATTRIBUTE THAT
COMPLETELY TO JUST RETAIL THEFT.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ELECT A
MAYOR THAT DOM, THEN YOU KIND OF
DESERVE WHAT YOU GET.
THE TRUTH IS NOT EVERYONE IN
SAN FRANCISCO VOTED FOR LONDON
BREED, DESPITE HER ALLURING
NAME.
THEY DON'T DESERVE THIS.
THE TRUTH IS YOU SHOULD NOT HAVE
DAILY LOOTING IN AMERICAN CITIES
BECAUSE IT IS A FIRST WORLD
COUNTRY.
THIS IS NOT SOME THIRD WORLD
HELL HALL, THIS IS THE COUNTRY
OUR ANCESTORS BUILT, A GREAT
COUNTRY, YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO STEAL, OKAY, PERIOD.
BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU CAN
STEAL AND OUR LEADERS ARE
TELLING YOU YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN
ABLE TO STEAL, IT IS OKAY.
YOU BRING YOUR KIDS TO SCHOOL
AND OH, WAIT A SECOND, THERE ARE
JUNKIES LIVING IN TENTS RIGHT
ACROSS FROM YOUR KIDS SCHOOL.
BUT THEY HAVE ALWAYS BEEN THERE,
TOO.
THEY WERE THERE WHEN YOU WERE A
KID, YOU JUST NEVER NOTICED.
READJUST YOUR EXPECTATIONS.
SETTLE DOWN, KAREN.
HERE IS SEATTLE'S MAYOR JENNY
DURKAN SAYING THEY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE JUNKIES LIVING IN TENTS
RIGHT NEXT TO THEIR SCHOOLS.
HERE IS A LOCAL NEWS REPORT FROM
SEATTLE.
>> BROADVIEW THOMPSON IS A
PUBLIC SCHOOL COME UP ITS
PROPERTY INCLUDES THIS GREEN
BELT, WAS TAKEN OVER BY DOZENS F
HOMELESS THAT NEIGHBORS THEY ARE
BRINGING EVEN MORE PROBLEMS.
>> THIS MORNING IN MY GARDEN, I
FOUND AN EMPTY PACKET THAT HAD
DRUGS IN IT.
>> DESPITE OUTRAGE FROM PARENTS
AND NEIGHBORS, TWO SEATTLE
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS ARE
REFUSING TO LET THE ENCAMPMENT
BEING CLEARED.
CLAIMING THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
PROPERTY IS PRIVATE PROPERTY AND
OFF-LIMITS WITHOUT AN
INVITATION.
>> Tucker: YEAH, THE ONE THING
YOU CAN'T DO IS EXPEL THE
JUNKIES.
NOT THE HOMELESS.
HOMELESS MAKES IT SOUND LIKE A
PROTECTED CLASS, THEY ARE
JUNKIES COME UP SHOOTING UP,
BREAKING INTO CARS TO SUPPORT
THEIR HABIT, SELLING
THEMSELVES, ON WOMEN, THEY ARE
JUNKIES, OKAY?
AND THEY ARE ON YOUR KIDS SCHOOL
LAWN.
BUT WE CAN'T INTERVENE IN THAT
BECAUSE IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN THAT
WAY.
JUST LOWER YOUR EXPECTATIONS,
KAREN.
IN NEW YORK CITY, POLICE HAVE
BEEN ORDERED TO NOT INTERVENE
WHEN THEY SEE JUNKIES SHOOTING
UP ON THE SIDEWALK OR IN A PARK.
CAN GET IN THE WAY.
AND YOU SHOULDN'T BECAUSE WE
HAVE ALWAYS HAD JUNKIES IN OUR
PARKS.
SAM ADAMS WAS ACTUALLY SMOKING
METH ON THE BOSTON COMMON ONCE
UPON A TIME.
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., THE METRO
BASICALLY SHUT DOWN UNTIL 60% OF
ITS TRAIN CARS -- THE COMMUTERS
HAVE TO FIND ANOTHER WAY TO GET
TO WORK BECAUSE THE TRAIN
SERVICE IS NOT WORKING ANYMORE.
JUST LOWER YOUR EXPECTATIONS.
IN FACT, THEY ARE LUCKY.
IN PHILADELPHIA LAST WEEK FOR
SEVERAL PEOPLE ON A TRAIN, AND I
GOT ON A TRAIN, THEN THEY GOT TO
WALK AS A MAN TO MAN'S B-29ED A
WOMAN ON THE TRAIN FOR MINUTES.
WITNESSES DESCRIBE WHAT THEY
SAW -- HERE IS PART OF IT.
>> IN UPPER DARBY, 69TH STREET
STATION, PASSENGERS OF THE LINE
ARE OUTRAGED.
>> THE ATTACK WAS BRUTAL, IT WAS
WICKED, AND THE WORST PART,
PEOPLE WERE WATCHING.
>> SEVERAL PEOPLE WATCHING, THE
DARBY SUPERINTENDENT OF POLICE
ARRESTED 35-YEAR-OLD FISHED
ANNOYED, WHO INVESTIGATORS SAY
IS SEEN ON A TRAIN SECURITY
CAMERA, SITTING NEXT TO THE
ALLEGED VICTIM, TOUCHING HER,
AND THEN RAPING HER.
A FEMALE EMPLOYEE STEPPED IN,
CALLED IN THE ATTACK, WHICH WAS
RELAYED ON RADIO ABOUT THE
ATTACKER DISROBING ON A TRAIN AT
56TH STREET STATION.
HE WAS ARRESTED AT 69TH STREET
STATION ON THE TRAIN, IN THE
ACT.
>> Tucker: THIS HAS ALWAYS
BEEN THE WAY AMERICA WORKS.
REMEMBER --
SHE WAS KILLED.
THE DIFFERENCE, THOUGH, WE WERE
SHOCKED BY THAT.
35 YEARS AGO, WHEN SHE DIED.
IN THIS CASE, PASSENGERS WATCH
THIS WOMAN GETS B-29ED BUT THEY
WERE ON THEIR PHONE.
THEY WERE ONLINE GAMING.
THE POLICE CHIEF OF
PHILADELPHIA'S TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY SO NOBODY WHO SAW IT
DID ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> I CAN TELL YOU PEOPLE WERE
HOLDING THEIR PHONE UP IN THE
DIRECTION OF THIS WOMAN BEING
ATTACKED.
>> Tucker: AND BY ATTACKED, TO
BE TOTALLY CLEAR AND I HATE TO
USE THE WORD, IT IS THE RIGHT
WORD, SHE WAS RAPED IN FRONT OF
ALL THESE PEOPLE AND THEY DID
NOTHING.
SO HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT ROOT
CAUSES, WHAT WERE THE ROOT
CAUSES OF THIS RAPE.
A35-YEAR-OLD CONGOLESE MAN WHO
APPARENTLY RAPED THIS WOMAN, HAS
A CRIMINAL RECORD AND SHOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN HERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE, ON AND OVERSTATE STUDENT
VISA AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED.
THAT SHOULD NEVER HAVE HAPPENED,
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN HERE,
AND THE ONLY REASON HE WAS HIS
BECAUSE HE AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
LIKE HIM HAVE BEEN INVITED HERE
BY PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY WHO
DON'T RIDE THE TRAIN.
THIS PARTICULAR MAN CAME TO THE
UNITED STATE IN 2012 ON A
STUDENT VISA.
THAT VISA ENDED IN 2015 BECAUSE
HE WAS NO LONGER A STUDENT.
COURT RECORDS SHOW HE RACKED UP
MULTIPLE --
OKAY, SO HERE IS SOMEONE IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, WHO IS
CONVICTED OF SEXUAL ABUSE AND
DRUGS, BUT HE IS STILL HERE?
SO WHY AREN'T THE PEOPLE WHO
ALLOWED HIM TO REMAIN HERE IN
JAIL THEMSELVES?
THEY CERTAINLY SHOULD BE.
THIS GUY WAS PUT IN IMMIGRATION
DETENTION BACK IN JANUARY 2018
BUT NEVER GOT DEPORTED BECAUSE
THE IMMIGRATION LEGAL SYSTEM
DECIDED HE SHOULD RECEIVE A
SPECIAL STAY OF REMOVAL.
SO HE GOT WHAT IS CALLED A
WITHHOLDING OF REMOVAL FROM AN S
AGO, BACK IN 2019.
ACCORDING TO COURT DOCUMENTS,
THAT DECISION CAME AFTER "THE
BOARD OF IMMIGRATION APPEALS
FOUND THE MISDEMEANOR
SEX OFFENSE WAS NOT "A SERIOUS
CRIME," JUST A MINOR
SEX OFFENSE, AND THEREFORE
INELIGIBLE FOR A WITHHOLDING
FROM REMOVAL.
TO RECAP, YOU CAN WALK INTO A
COUNTRY AT THE INVITATION OF OUR
LEADERS AT PUBLIC EXPENSE, YOU
CAN OVERSTAY YOUR VISA AND IN SO
DOING MOCK OUR LAWS, THEN GET
BUSTED FOR DRUGS AND A
SEX CRIME, NOT DEPORTED, ALLOWED
TO STAY, THEN YOU GO ON,
PROBABLY INEVITABLY, TO RAPE A
WOMAN ON A TRAIN IN FULL VIEW OF
A CROWD THAT DOES NOTHING TO
STOP IT.
BUT IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN THIS WAY.
DON'T GET UPTIGHT.
READJUST YOUR EXPECTATIONS.
YOU WANT MORE OF THIS?
YOU MAY BE GETTING IT.
TODAY, JOE BIDEN'S NOMINEE TO
LEAD THE BORDER PATROL SET FOR
HIS CONFIRMATION HEARING.
IT TURNS OUT IF ANYTHING, HE IS
TO THE LEFT OF BY THEN, EVEN TO
THE LEFT OF BARACK OBAMA ON
IMMIGRATION MATTERS.
JUST A YEAR AGO WHEN HE WAS THE
POLICE CHIEF OF TUCSON, ARIZONA,
HE REJECTED A FEDERAL PROGRAM
CALLED OPERATION STONE GUARD
SUPPORTED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THE POINT TO
HELP BORDER TOWNS FIGHT CARTEL
VIOLENCE AND DRUG TRAFFICKING.
THAT WOULD SEEM A WORTHY GOAL,
NOT REALLY DIRECTLY RELATED TO
IMMIGRATION, DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THE DEATHS OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS.
BUT CHRIS MAGNESS IN HIS WISDOM
REJECTED THAT MONEY.
HIS OWN POLICE DEPARTMENT WAS
OUTRAGED BY THIS BUT
CHRIS MAGNUS DID NOT CARE, HE IS
A DEEPLY GOOD PERSON, UNLIKE
YOU, HE IS HAPPY TO ABET THE
DEATHS OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
BY DRAGO D.
HE SAID THE MONEY IN THE MISSION
OF STOPPING DRUG CARTELS DID NOT
ALIGN WITH HIS WORK.
HERE YOU HAVE THE PERSON ABOUT
TO OVERSEE OUR COUNTRY'S BORDER
SECURITY, WHO DOES NOT BELIEVE
IN BORDERS.
NOW IF THAT BOTHERS YOU IN ANY
WAY, IF YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE
DEPORTING RAPISTS INSTEAD OF
LETTING THEM RAPE WOMEN ON
TRAINS, THEN THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
A VERY CLEAR MESSAGE FOR YOU: A
SHUT UP, KAREN, STOP
COMPLAINING.
THAT TREADMILL